all right so you briefly mentioned
WikiLeaks over there I didn't know as a
Democrat if you were going to bring it
up I had it in my notes here but you did
bring it up so tell I mean are you guys
concerned do you think this is all the
questions are trying to take over our
election that's my line and I'm sticking
yeah no I mean really what all right as
a media relation up just tell me what
your general thoughts are on the content
do you believe the content to be real um
that's a great question actually because
you know we do a lot of work with the
Dancy here and we just had a situation
last week where there were emails to the
DNC supposedly from John Podesta and
they were fake and so it all of a sudden
we said we you know kind of believed
what people have been saying all along
it's like wow they're really can be
planted emails in this huge dump so as a
practical matter no I I don't feel like
I could say that they're they're
augmented okay so separating from that
which it seems to be the jury seems to
be out on that and you know I attended
Sirota on this week who is saying that
if the DNC or hillary campaign could
have you know for sure said we even
found one fake one that certainly they
would have let us know but well I think
you could just chalk it up to we're not
totally sure at the moment on the
Michael Isikoff story and yahoo the
other day because they gave him the fake
emails to look at okay great
investigative reporter all right I'll
definitely take a look at that all right
so removing that portion from it as
someone that again has worked with
campaigns and things like that do you
think there's anything in there you know
I know their stuff that's not you know
it sounds like they're giving stories to
friendlys at the new york times or some
you know some stuff that kind of sounds
like pay to play I mean stepping away
from the campaign a little bit do you
think there's anything in there that
that really strikes you as
untoward or or really bad um I don't I
feel like it's the kind of day to day
back and forth that happens on any
campaign the should we do this or this
is the downside of doing that and so I I
haven't really seen anything where I
thought oh [ __ ] that's really really bad
um what about what about giving stories
to friendlys as they've called that we
know that that obviously exists and that
goes to what I'm talking about before
about just the relationship between the
press and politicians but do you think
there's something that at least even
just even if it's just optics do you
think there's a problem there well not
for the campaign um it you know it's not
it's not great for the media outlet but
I don't think it's bad for the campaign
because the campaign is doing its job I
think from for the media outlet you know
again you have to look at the whole of
the of the coverage I don't think that
people would say that the New York Times
has been easy on Hillary Clinton now the
last couple of weeks they've been really
tough on Donald Trump but as I said I
don't you know I don't think you could
you could argue that they gave her a
free ride so I I don't think that those
were any sort of you know major problems
and you know there are a couple of other
things in there that I think we're
embarrassing you know conversations that
they probably would really not want to
have public if there were accurate but I
didn't say anything that really troubled
me that much I I sort of felt the same
way around the excerpts of the Goldman
Sachs speeches which is there didn't
seem to be anything in there that was so
troubling um what it was a more what
about the lineup yeah what about the
line about you know you guys are the
experts so you should kind of police
yourselves well she didn't say you
should police yourself she said you
should participate and that was a big
difference there and I mean that's just
factually true you are experts it
doesn't mean there aren't
there are other experts to who need a
seat at the table but I don't see
anything wrong with inviting industry to
the table I don't think they should own
the table or run the table but I think
that how can you make smart laws if you
don't you know have people there who are
going to tell you its impact you don't
always have to believe them but you want
to hear it yeah let's clip back to trump
for a second because this reminds me
sort of if you were handling him if he
was coming to you for sage wisdom he
probably you probably pay a lot for that
right that's that that would not come
cheap to try would not be eight that
word of Ichi I don't know if there's
enough money in Trump Tower to pay me
and o'donnell so but if he came to you
and what you said before about the line
that we know I mean we see every day the
amount of lies that he lays out per day
sometimes I think they're somewhat
overblown but we know it's just like a
factual mess the things that he's saying
every day it's like Tourette's or
something with him so as a media
relations person it seems pretty obvious
to me that despite the lies he just has
forged through them and that and that he
said you know what was the line about I
could shoot someone in the middle of the
street nobody would care it's like he's
realized that the more he doubles down
on this the more that it works in your
history of media relations have you ever
seen an example of something like this
before never never and I say that more
emphatically never I've never seen this
and in fact you know if I had a client
that I was media training you know it
would be that kind of cluelessness about
the about the impact you were having
that I would try and beat out of them um
you know I you know make them practice
and rehearse over and over again to try
and look like they actually cared about
someone other than themselves um you
know and what does that insane in our
line of work then if it's if it's even
if he loses the election that he has
sustained this for so long treating the
media this way what does that say
well we'll look at the numbers right
because you can get some people to
believe anything but it's what you get a
majority of people to believe so he's
got the biggest audience he's ever had
in his life and and you know in his
career maybe for his future thirty-six
percent is great you know what were the
trunk hotels market share before then
right so i but i but it's not persuasive
to to a majority of people and it's not
effective it's it's working with some
people but I it's not working with most
people yeah all right let's step away
from all the day-to-day election stuff
and the media stuff at the same time and
just talk about politics in a kind of
broader sense even though you're a
Democrat would you like to see more
parties I mean it's really hit me more
than ever I consider myself independent
but we definitely we desperately need
more parties I would love if there was
an actual you know libertarian or
classical liberal party I think if we
had a functional not Jill Stein LEED
Green Party I think that would be fine
do you think even though even though you
obviously like the Democrats do you
think that for the health of democracy
that we need more parties wow that's a
big good question I I I know your
paycheck is slightly related to the
answer so you know no what's not really
um I think that that it would be freeing
in a way if people could narrow their
interests more um you know i'm i'm a
little more of a centrist Democrat on
some things and a little more left on
other things so um but uh and and i
think that we're going to see a really
significant struggle in the republican
party over the next six or eight months
but to reconcile their factions but
I'm not sweeping under the rug the
factions in the Democratic Party so it's
a it's appealing to think about it and
imagine that then we could have real
coalition government as opposed to
partisan government you know we we've
seen it work in Europe and then we've
seen it sort of blow apart in Europe so
um I guess I'm open to it but I think
it's a function of I guess it feels hard
to get to yeah what would you tell
hillary if she wins we somehow got right
back to it but what would you tell
hillary if she wins about reaching
across the aisle and look no matter what
she does assuming she wins a certain
percentage of the Trump people an
extremely high percentage you're going
to hate her no matter what what would
you tell her as far as if you want to
get even ten percent of them that might
be malleable and flexible in thinking to
come on board what how would you
instruct her to do that I think she
actually understands this question very
well and you know as a you know
president you're not a dictator but in
this instance if we have multiple
factions you are a little more like a
prime minister and a president in a way
because you have to find ways to bring
Republicans together Liberal Democrats
together with centrist democrats you
have to get some moderate Republicans in
I think the Republican majority in the
house is going to shrink some and the
next speaker will have to decide if
they're willing to pass things with some
Democratic votes because there's going
to be a faction of right-wing boats
they're never going to get if they try
and come to the table so I do think that
Hillary actually is a really good leader
for those times because she's not so
politically bound you know people see
her as such a partisan but in fact she's
really not she's more she's more issue
focused than she is
literally focused do you think you'll
miss the old school Republicans I mean
this split that's breaking like did you
ever think there would be a day where
you'd suddenly be like you know Paul
Ryan and Lindsey Graham and a couple of
those old guys if polarize not old but
like just the lighting honey that you
know Paul Ryan and Lindsey Graham used
to be considered fairly right-wing I
think it's [ __ ] that they're now the
moderates you know when I'm old so to me
is sort of the moderates were like Arlen
Specter and drinkin baby and people like
that so you know they're they don't even
exist in a republican party anymore
right so to that point do you think
they'll you'll miss some adjust whatever
whatever the old Republicans are be it
from the Arlen specters of the back in
the day to Paul Ryan now that like that
thing that Republican conservative thing
short of them having some crazy
resurgence assuming Trump loses and they
they go back to their roots I mean it
really seems over you think you'll be
nostalgic for whatever oh I already am
because I did it's some you know people
like that who have first of all help
social progress like I'm a LGBT activist
in my spare time and if you look at the
you know the few times we actually won
votes on Capitol Hill we won votes with
Republicans we you know wasn't just yeah
we got the majority of Democrats but we
stopped the constitutional amendment to
ban you know same-sex marriage with
eight Republican votes in the Senate and
and the majority Democrats that couldn't
happen today we couldn't find eight
Republicans to vote with us on an issue
because they're so you know there's such
bad consequences for them to cross over
party lines on issues and so I think
that that you know we report more poorly
served as a country without our
moderates yeah I'm curious that my
audience knows I I criticized the left
more because I consider myself part of
the left as a liberal are there anything
is there anything going on on the left
right now that you're not thrilled about
like when it comes to some of the
political correctness stuff or the free
speech stuff or any of that do you see
cause for concern or am i blowing it out
of proportion on Twitter no I think it I
think there's a you know a couple of
things I where you see where you see
just sort of demonizing anyone who works
on Wall Street like I I don't get paid
by Ne Win a Wall Street I've no clients
on Wall Street I have no dog in this
fight but that doesn't mean that I don't
think there isn't like some expertise
around financing that is still kind of
useful to have somewhere around the
government um I'm I'm a clean air and
clean water advocate I'm happy that we
are moving towards wind and solar an
alternative energy but I don't I don't
see how we you know we're not there
overnight right we need some interim
steps I you know people are not giving
up their cars they don't this we still
want our house is cleaned we need a
backup generator as it were so the sort
of the purity caucus i think is where i
end up kind of parting ways and i'm i'm
much more conservative for instance on
taxes I if a company makes money and
wants to hire more people with that
money it's like fine I'd rather them
hire more people than pay higher
corporate taxes which is I know annan
asum out of my liberal friends right I
was wrong with you if they if they take
that money and pay it out to their
executives we ought to tax their income
really well like tap some high you know
like I don't I don't like the disparity
between CEO pay and regular worker pay i
think that's obscene and so if they end
up using their corporate profits to pay
their senior executives a lot of money
then that those people should be taxed a
lot on that income but if they want to
use their profits to create jobs and
more growth and more opportunity like
i'd rather see the money go there yeah
so so when you see or what happened with
Trump's taxes and the nine
180 million whatever knowing that what
that assuming what he did is legal
because no one's saying it's illegal
bait you don't have a moral problem with
it like that's more of like a systemic I
do that's that's personal income tax
right that you get a ridiculous amount
of benefits from real estate in
particular like the the esoteric nature
of taxing you know real estate
professionals is that's obscene to it's
your your assets appreciating but yet
you're depreciating the you know the the
buildings that you own it that makes no
sense to me right but but you're you
make the distinction between him just
using the law which he did versus doing
something illegal right you don't like
what he did basically but but a lot of
people do it right oh I don't like what
he did and i don't i don't actually
think that that's a good you know it's
not a good use of corporate dollars so i
i'm all for him paying significant taxes
there i'm making a different distinction
like above a company or a small
businesses as earning money and with
their profit they are growing their
business hiring more jobs I'm not
talking about taking a loss I'm just
saying my interest is not in raising
their taxes Roger and my interest would
be in raising the taxes if they pay
their bosses too much money yeah all
right I to I have two more questions for
you and then and then you're free to go
to the fancy DC parties or and I'm gonna
get all these like crazy notes on this
dude attack you would mine but whatever
the Twitter people are going to be out
the Trump people on Twitter they just
are if I bring that if i write me about
my tax views I'm like not an expert you
just asked me if I had a thought about
like where we get a little too crazy on
the lab trust me even by be asking
certain questions they yell at me it's
okay that's what free speech is all that
so two questions uh before before we end
here after this election you think
there's gonna be just like a little
brief healing period cuz I actually do
like just where people just November
night's gonna come one of them's going
to be the winner
I actually do think there's going to be
a couple weeks of like we're in this
thing it just feels so intense for
everybody even my friends my best
childhood friend who is not political at
all if you asked him who the Vice
President is right now I don't think he
would know but he's been all about this
election do you think there's just going
to be some natural cathartic thing that
happens in the country after this I
think there will be a big exhale like oh
my God thank God it is over yeah um I I
do worry about Hillary Clinton I think
it's going to be hard to be Hillary
Clinton you know to to get up and and
find the words that make the entire
country believe that you can move past
what has been such a you know ugly
unhealthy conversation is hard and well
maybe scrub check some of the
conversation actually is healthy right
some of the stuff that you know when
Donald Trump is gross about women like I
said people there's been a really great
conversation about sexual harassment
that we wouldn't have had otherwise but
but it's not that this election has not
brought out the best in America and I do
think that people want the best in
America so I'm hopeful that she's going
to give it a give it a good show at the
end fair enough alright final question
on the record what are the percentages
what are we looking at here after rely
on Election Day Wow I'm asking that's
right that's right I have been thinking
that she would that the winner would not
break fifty percent because of the third
party candidates and and the like but I
actually think now that that she could
get fifty one percent of the popular
vote and he'll be in the high 30s and
we're gonna see a stronger third party
boat than we anticipated that's my
prediction all right listen I tried to
do my best to help gary johnson i did a
whole video about how we got to get the
guy to fifteen percent and let's do it
unfortunately he didn't live up to your
own faith in him no he didn't i feel
like he owes me a steak dinner that's
what i've been tweeting hilary has
really been a pleasure you know you did
my old siriusxm show you were like one
of the first like real people we got on
when we were a struggling little thing
and i really appreciate that and I
appreciate you joining me today you're
great and I love your sensibility keep
at it alright thanks so much and you
guys can follow Hillary on the Twitter
it's at Hillary our that's just with one
L don't get her confused with the other
Hillary although people have gotten
confused in my right now no one's ever
gotten confused oh yeah there there was
a story actually yeah there was a story
I want to look like Hillary Clinton so I
could be a look-alike and after she's
president there couldn't work in that
all right Hillary's back so much
you